if you're watching a movie and someone
is attempting to do fancy mathematics on
a chalkboard you'll almost always see a
symbol that looks like this this is a
radical symbol and this is used this is
used to the square root and we'll see
other types of roots as well but your
question is well what does this thing
actually mean and now that we know a
little bit about exponents we'll see
that the square root symbol or the root
symbol or the radical is not so is not
so hard to understand so let's start
with an example
so we know that 3 to the 2nd power is
what 3 squared is what well that's the
same thing as 3 times 3 that's going to
be equal to 9 but what if we went the
other way around what if we started with
a 9 and we said well what time's itself
is equal to 9 we only know that answer
is 3 but how could we how could we use a
symbol that tells us that so as you can
imagine that symbol is this is going to
be the radical here so we can write the
square root of 9 and when you look at
this way you say ok what squared is
equal to 9 and you would say well this
is going to be equal to this is going to
be equal to 3 and I want you to really
look at these two these two these two
equations right over here because this
is the essence of the square root symbol
if you say the square root of 9 you're
saying what time's itself is equal to 9
and well that's going to be 3 and 3
squared is equal to 9 I can do that
again I can do that many times I can
write 4 4 squared is equal to 16 well
what's the square root of 16 going to be
well it's going to be equal to
it's going to be equal to 4 let me do it
again and actually let me start with the
square root what is the square root of
25 going to be well this is the number
that times itself is going to be equal
to 25 or the number where if I were
squared I get 225 well what number is
that well that's going to be equal to 5
why because we know that 5 squared is
equal to Phi
squared is equal to 25 now I know that
there's a little nagging feeling that
some of you might be having because if I
were to take if I were to take negative
three and square it and square it I
would also get positive nine and the
same thing if I were to take negative
four and I were to square the whole
thing I would also get positive sixteen
or negative five and F R squared I would
also get positive 25 so why couldn't
this thing right over here why can't the
square root the positive 3 or negative 3
well depending on who you talk to that's
actually a reasonable thing to think
about but when you see a radical simple
light a symbol like this people usually
call this the principal root principle
root principle principle square root
square root and another way to think
about it it's the positive this is going
to be the positive square root if
someone wants the negative square root
of 9 they might say something like this
they might say the negative let me
scroll up a little bit they might say
something like the negative square root
of 9 well that's going to be equal to
negative 3 and what's interesting about
this is well if you square both sides of
this of this equation if you were to
square both sides of this equation what
do you get well negative anything
negative squared becomes a positive and
then the square root of 9 squared well
that's just going to be 9 and on the
right hand side negative 3 squared well
negative 3 times negative 3 is positive
9 so it all works out nine is equal 9 is
equal to 9 and so this is an interesting
thing actually let me let me write this
a little bit more algebraically now if
we were to write if we were to write the
principal root of 9 is equal to X this
is this there's only one possible
excerpt that satisfies it because the
standard convention what most math Matt
what most mathematicians have agreed to
view this radical symbol as is that this
is the principal square root this is the
positive square root so there's only one
X here the
only 1x that would satisfy this and that
is X is equal to 3 now if I were to
write x squared is equal to 9 now this
is slightly definitely x equals 3
definitely satisfies this this could be
x equals 3 but the other thing the other
X that satisfies this is X could also be
X's could also be equal to negative 3
because negative 3 squared is also equal
to 9 so these two things these two
statements are almost equivalent
although when you're looking at this one
there's two X's that satisfy this one
well there's only one X that satisfies
this one because this is the positive
square root if people wanted to write
something equivalent where you would
have two x's that could satisfy it you
might see something like this plus or
minus square root of 9 is equal to X and
now X could take on positive 3 or
negative 3